blake snell making his ninth start of
the season this is the time for the big
guy to step up right now
and a cut in a mess he got him to chase
up that time just challenged him that
was very well done there by blake all
with the heater and sending a message
too to this boston lineup i'm coming
after you tonight the pitch on its way
swinging and a miss he struck him out a
pretty impressive first inning for blake
snell as he blows away the red sox so
the reigns top to bottom with
left-handed hitters and so far as we
know
that's the first time that's happened in
the major leagues and andrew triggs the
right-hander about to make his second
start his third appearance for the red
sox 0-1 with boston so with two outs the
reigns have put two men on
against the right-hander triggs and
kevin kiermeier is on his way to the
play
hammered again to the right side arroyo
fires on to get him and triggs gets out
of it leaving two
red sox's plans would have it
with all these left-handed batters in
the lineup here comes the lefty and matt
hall
but yossi satsugo will lead it off here
in the second the 2-2 pitch here's a
swing and a drive right center field and
deep if there were rays in the in the
pool they'd get a little company as it
falls into the netting where the ray
tank would be and yoshi tsutsugo has
just hit his seventh home run of the
season well i guess maybe the red sox
played right into the raised hands since
tsugo lefty on lefty goes deep go to the
third one-letting rage i want to know
the count
ground ball third setsugo lao one time
to go to first for the double play five
four three
so now two one with two out for zander
bogart
and a tapper back to the mound
and that will take care of that
first and second one out and up steps
kevin
two and one
pier meyer swing since a slow grinder
back towards the middle wendell breaks
for the plate he will score bogarts
picks it up and throws to first for the
out down to third goes lau and because
of the double steel the rays get a run
and lead two nothing first and second
one out ray's lead two nothing because
austin meadows is coming up
fly ball toward right center field long
run bradley on the move can't get there
won't hop into the wall lowe's going to
score perez will follow him to the plate
here's the throw and he has saved the
ball skipping by vasquez a double for
austin meadows driving home to
around so far this left-handed hitting
lineup exclusively putting up
four runs off the left-hander matt hall
and the reigns have a four-nothing lead
and a cut and a mesh chavis out on
strikes
and a miss he goes upstairs
gets the chase at 96. the slider's been
good here tonight elevate the fastball
he's had it all working
christian vasquez
counting tonight three of 11 in his
career against blake snell now the 3-2
to vasquez and a ground ball third off
the glove of satsugo backed up by
wendell
tsetsugo got the glove down there and
thinking about maybe a hurried throw to
second
and now two men on with only one out and
here comes kevin cash blake snell who
works five and a third and leaves with
two men on repeat fairbanks
will get the call he was in the game
last night three one pitch here's a
swing and a grounder towards short could
be two fielded by wendell the second out
turn to first and plenty of time for the
double play
tech data double play of the ball game
and that will retire the sun nate lowe
who singled his last time
the 01 pitch is swinging and lifted to
the right field and fairly deep alex
verdugo back to the wall jumps up and
it's gone
it knocked out a cardboard cutout
took him right out of the seat
but nate lowe hits his first home run of
2020 and he gives the raise a
five-nothing lead two men on two walks
one out
and here's shitsugo
round ball through the left side base
hit
choi rounds third he will score
kiermeier goes to third on the base hit
by sudsugo driving in his second round
it's six nothing raised no homer in the
sixth inning
now fly ball to the opposite side toward
the low wall that one is gone
home runs second home run of the night
for nate lowe
a three-run blast for low the other way
the rays break it open here in the
seventh
graders have had men on base and every
inning in this game except the fifth
there's a hit into right center field
wendell scores lau heads to third into
second base goes choi
and the rays tack on another run on the
double by choi
ball right side
throw to first in time
and the rays have scored their 11th run
of the game
of the night aaron loop is on
fly ball into right field along the line
that's going to drop
jackie bradley rounding third he is on
his way in the throw comes in late to
second base so the red sox are on the
board bobby dolby with his 10th rbi
and now verdugo
ground ball right side glove there
and the throw to first
is in time
loud of joy
to win this one an 11-1 final